[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum baum
and uh ryan tez is here hola i noticed
some people uh comment on the show
whether it's on youtube or online uh you
know twitter and all that stuff people
do
say things about you they just say
things about me no they're just saying
you know they're like i like ryan they
like ryan there's a guy there
there's this guy ryan because michael
can't be alone because michael can't be
alone
ryan a new film by jerry brookheimer
that would that's good cause michael
can't be alone
ryan
the new thriller it's someone that's
craving somebody can make a poster but
that's nice thank you everyone yeah yeah
people love you uh thanks for listening
guys uh as as i say every week without
you we're not here so there's so many
podcasts to choose from and you choose
us at least today because you like this
guest
coming up and uh she's been on the show
before but she really talks openly
candidly
erica durants she's here um we thank you
we thank you for listening and if you
want to um leave a review
it really helps the podcast at insider
you pod on the twitter at insideypodcast
on the instagram and facebook
um and we're on youtube so please
subscribe and write a review it helps um
you know somebody uh you know it's
always that one person that bothers you
that says something on a comment on a on
a youtube
that you're just kind of like motherly
and they're just like
yeah you know it's like i'm gonna just
fast forward past you telling everybody
to watch the show and write a review
something like that like i forgot what
it was
i was like dude i responded to him i
wasn't mean but i was like how how do
you expect me to promote my show you
idiot
i mean what do you want me to do
i mean you're not an idiot if you're
listening thank you for listening
well we need more of you but you know
it's just like i got to do that i got to
promote the show so there you go hey uh
my band stage it uh my band sunspin is
going to be playing on stage it please
get tickets if you haven't seen the band
we're coming out with a new album soon
the band is sun spin go to sunspin.com
get tickets for the concert we're going
to be on stage it on the um
may
28th saturday 2 p.m and a 6 p.m show uh
pacific standard time so get your
tickets there's prizes zooms all that
also uh the inside of your online store
is available for tons of merch
smallville merch autographs all that
um what else i'm on the cameo and you
know whoring yourself here the patreon
um the patreon my patrons if you go to
patreon.com inside of you without you
guys i don't exist so if you want to
join patreon and help the podcast you
can in that way in many ways ryan what's
going on with you anything uh anything
fun anything intriguing you're going to
ireland soon uh yeah going a lot of
places soon yeah
all of a sudden
uh
going to
england france
spain
for one of them
good lord yeah
really tired yeah for two weeks i'm
tired thinking about you going to these
places
i'm going to st louis by the way um yeah
so
after this will have aired but i'll be
in liverpool this coming weekend and
then um metropolis illinois june 10th
weekend and australia for supanova in
perth and sydney so i'll be gone as well
so we're both traveling a lot yeah yeah
which i haven't done
no you haven't done a lot of traveling
no this will be good i saw my parents
but that's about it just northern
california
and uh
that's really it i went to hawaii you
went through why you liked hawaii but oh
i got a little old after a while
yeah it's uh hawaii vegas there's some
places that you can only do for like so
many
yeah that's what happens how many days
that's what happens you're like hey i'm
here i'm here i'm gonna be home yeah
it's amazing how you just want to get
back home
after
a certain amount of time you just you
miss home no matter how much you love
being somewhere else being home is the
best
it just is for me anyway great show
today i think you're gonna really enjoy
this without further ado i love this
lady she's beautiful inside and out and
uh she is uh really fun to talk to i
hope she'll come on the podcast every
year i try to get my old buddies from
smallville to come on here at least once
a year so without further ado let's get
inside of erica durants it's my point of
view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience i don't walk around like this i
just put on my fancy new shirt
for my interview what do you have an
interview first of all you look
fantastic i don't know what it is is it
your hair is it i don't know but you
look really good i'm not lying lots of
lighting on in here it could be because
i've learned that if i wear color it
makes me look less dead and old so
a tide of color
now
why are you what's what's the big
interview for
what is it
you
oh it's me i'm the big interview
hi you're michael rosenbaum you dressed
up for me i did
i love it where are you you're in canada
right i am in canada vancouver bc
vancouver bc
when's the last time you went home to
calgary
oh
god like two years
really you haven't been there in two
years do you have any family there still
no i have a brother in edmonton hmm
and that's not the destination point of
travel really i mean he would say the
same thing i love him dearly but he
comes to me
well that's nice
no he's like you don't have to come to
edmonton edmonton's known for their big
mall and the edmonton oilers of course
because he's been it's so cold there
that you have to spend some time inside
should i be matching you with
intellectual
put on your glasses i i think you look
great without glasses and with but i
like without better really nerdy about
me so when i was a kid uh my sister got
glasses in grade three and i was in
grade one and i've always wanted them
and so last year
i just had the slightest problem with my
vision
anybody who actually needs glasses put
some on and then you're such an idiot
but i technically
need them for for night driving
he almost said drunk driving i was like
well the drunk driving needs glasses as
well because things just get blurry yeah
you don't drink and drive you're not
even a big drinker
i know you don't i'm not even out past
seven most of the times am i allowed to
tell uh the folks here what uh i
received a text
this morning from you
and it just said i so needed this
oh yeah
cause you got a movie i did another
homework movie i'm so excited what's it
called
it's working title
i don't you don't know
no they're just saying working title
hallmark maybe but
the 10 pages i read before i said yes
were amazing
you said yes without knowing anything
ah it's like it can't be that bad you
know no i read it it was good and what i
like about hallmark is at least the last
three that i've done
maybe it's because i'm older and so i'm
i'm doing different roles but it's not
quite the same love story
they they still have to service a
certain demographic and it has to be
somebody falls in love at some point
doing something right
life is all better and those kinds of
things and it's all positive and good
but
each like i did three so i did one with
alice and johnny in the fall and that
was more about two best alice and janie
no not listen
i think so you want to work with allison
obviously you did one with allison
janney i was like all right
oh my god
so if so what you just you did one alice
in sweeney alice's swing
thanks for the compliment i think
because allison johnny is awesome yeah
she is pretty awesome um she's in the
back of my mind she's one of my heroes
um anyways that one was about best
friends and then the ones that then i
did one in
in december which was called north to
home and that was about sisters
healing their past and learning to love
each other i sound like i'm mocking it
i'm not no i don't think you're mocking
at all i i think you're just telling me
about it you're i think you're excited
you're giddy you're just like hey i got
this job and you know maybe it sounds
like you but when you said you needed it
what what why are you just a little uh
you know how's your anxiety i know we
talked about it last time how's all that
stuff going how you've been how have you
been dealing with it
depends on which time of day you catch
me is it is it sort of like you know in
the mornings it's tough and then in the
afternoon it gets easier one moment
and it's not this isn't a sexy story but
anybody who's had like really down
moments knows that you somehow at 3am
you end up in a bathroom why are you in
your bathroom
why aren't you still just on the couch
upset
but i just ended up in my bathroom in
the bathtub fully clothed so it's not
exciting no water i was just in there
shaking just like
i was tweezing
really
and as i was chatting with my sister
um
i thought to myself why is it that i end
up in the bathroom she goes i do the
same thing so maybe you could put it out
there when are true anxiety moments
where do you end up it's just your safe
place
it's your safe place you're getting a
bathtub it sounds like a safe place for
an earthquake
are you supposed to get in the bathtub
during an earthquake or a tornado what
are you are you ever supposed to get in
the bathtub you're supposed to when
there was that movie where they got in
the bathtub it was
lethal weapon
she pulls out a movie from 4 30 years
ago
they got in the bathtub and it kept
things from exploding on them
maybe that's what it was maybe that oh
yeah maybe that's it
i don't know but i do i do have anxiety
but i'm also working on ways
to manage it now look i don't know i'm
not a doctor i'm not like someone who
knows everything that's for sure
but it feels like to me
that you got you get anxiety
you're you know you're uncomfortable
there's your ups and downs you go in the
bathroom you're freaking out a little
bit but then you get a job
and everything starts to dissipate or
just
re you relax a little more is that true
yeah i think i think that is true i
don't want to say that it's all based
around working right but what but it is
based around things that for example if
somebody said thinks they have a sense
of purpose
right
um and they can focus all of that
intensity somewhere and say this is what
i'm gonna do so depending on what you've
how you've validated yourself or what
your
what your kind of pattern has been your
whole life if if that's interrupted and
changed then it can create anxiety so
for me
you know i started working as
as a janitor um when i was 10. wait
wait wait i was waitress a janitor
yeah where were you a janitor
my family we cleaned the local
um
no no no it's good i'm just like wow at
10 years old she was doing janitorial
things that's that's cool and that's why
i'm still a bit of a neat freak and i
can't i always clean up after myself in
movie theaters right
um so when i was a kid our family
decided we needed to make more money and
so we cleaned a few of the buildings on
main street after school and everything
and then i really liked having money
so then i was a waitress at 15 as soon
as i could get my card
and then i've been working ever since
and so for me to go from
working and then getting kind of
such such a great job on smallville and
then going onto saving hope like
i had this rhythm this is what i did i
wanted to go out work come home and not
spend 10 hours at home like
and so
it was a bit of
a bit difficult
not having children but changing
that pattern
right and redefining myself yeah
and um
so
getting little bits of work is kind of
nice again yeah
i like i like to do it i like to tell
stories i like to create you like
working you like being on set you like
people i feel like it's a bad thing to
say i actually really like working no i
think it's a beautiful thing to say i
think you're very grateful and it seems
like you know work makes you happy as it
should you
if you're lucky enough to do it to have
a job that makes you happy you wouldn't
want the jackpot in a lot of ways yeah
right
and again like i love i love my boys
there the loves of my life how many how
many boys
i have three my eldest is 22 and then my
two littlest babies are five and seven
but what ends up happening and most
women will say this too is if you don't
have a deflection if you don't have
another thing that is yours at some
point you just keep giving more of you
you you to an intensity where you kind
of lose yourself a little bit you lose
what you even liked to do before
and it actually isn't healthy for them
either they may not see it the young
ones don't see it at the time because
they're just like little taking
um minions more more more
you know but at some point they don't
like it either it's not healthy for them
yeah so i'm into that kind of transition
too because the five and seven year old
are in school now
and they're getting past that mommy face
i've been reading books let's see
this one is called the boy crisis
oh wow
look at you educating yourself
that's cool so this is to educate you on
what to expect and that sort of thing
for boys right now all those kinds of
things but also to what to expect with
their growth process so from zero to six
it's all about mommy and she teaches
them about empathy and interaction and
socializing and being okay with their
emotions and all of those things now
this is very stereotypical it can be
males can teach this to you
but then once they get into like a 7 to
12 then they start looking in okay what
can dad teach me about the world right
so
we're just in a transition that way are
you saying daddy becomes the favorite is
that what you're saying it's mommy and
then daddy and it kind of goes back and
forth
so
he's he's the favorite up until the
point they need to like throw up or
garbage
because that's mom i remember there was
a kid across the street throw stuff at
me
you know like
yeah
inside of you is brought to you by sofi
look guys i don't know about you but it
is impossible for me with all these all
these apps on investing and i want to
invest people need to invest for the
future and you can't just put your money
in a bank for making zero dollars on it
you know you want to invest some money
in and uh it's it's confusing as hell
yeah most of these apps are confusing so
far is not confusing but a lot of these
things have these this jargon these
jargon terms like mame stocks and uh
altcoin and shilling and i just don't
know where to begin i really don't know
where to begin and so fi makes it so
much
easier whether you're eager to get
started with investing or you already
know the ropes and want to diversify
your portfolio sofi has your back no
commissions on trading stocks and etfs
plus no account fees or hidden fees use
fractional shares that start as low as
five dollars to buy brand name stocks
even if you don't have a couple of grand
lying around complimentary financial
planners are ready to help with any
questions whether you're stuck on where
to start or need help deciding what to
do next good because that's what i need
i need someone to walk me through these
things and you have them you have these
complimentary financial planners right
there for you save for retirement with
traditional roth and scp iras get
hands-on with active investing or let
sofi's number one ranked automated
investing tool or robo advisor take the
stress out of building and managing a
diversified portfolio by doing it for
you you can set your own investment
goals from saving for retirement to
building up a down payment quarterly
auto rebalancing with no sofi management
fee explore the world of cryptocurrency
alongside the rest of your investments
yeah 30 available coins including
bitcoin ethereum cardano solano dogecoin
and more sofi protects against fraud and
theft to keep your crypto secure redeem
reward points into crypto
cut through the jargon and make
investing easier with sofi visit
sofi.com
inside to learn how you can win up to 1
000 in stock when you open an account
that's sofi.com
inside brokerage and active investing
products offered through sofi securities
llc member finra
sipc all investments involve risks
including the loss of principle past
performance does not guarantee future
results or future performance inside of
you is brought to you by wondering
and uh you know we're going to talk
about life is short with justin long for
just a second i don't listen to many
podcasts but i enjoy his because he's
open and candid like i am and uh that's
what i'll say about that uh he's just a
likable dude and he uh you know he has
the ability to get people to open up as
well so i like you justin i like you
okay that's what i'll say how do we make
the most of our time here on earth
how do we bring meaning to our life's
work and what is the best emoji to use
when texting these are the important
questions asked on the weekly interview
podcast life is short with justin long
in each episode actor justin long chats
with celebrities actors musicians
artists and more about how they get the
most out of life in recent episodes hear
his conversations with severance actor
adam scott comedian nicole byer and
prolific author mark epstein you'll get
the inside scoop on their careers and of
course learn their favorite emojis too
listen to life is short with justin long
on apple podcasts amazon music or you
can listen one week early and ad free by
joining wondering plus in the wondery
app inside of you is brought to you by
better help
life can be overwhelming and many people
are burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped detachment
fatigue and more
we associate burnout with work but
that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out and better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than an
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours
inside of you listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's better
dot com slash inside get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com
inside
i remember i remember across the street
from my house growing up
there's this couple and they had this
little girl
she was tiny and i remember she was
picking her nose
and the dad goes there you go there you
go get it
get it
roll it
roll it now give it to mommy
i just remember that
they do that too my kids still give me
their biggers they do i got a booger and
now i'm getting to the point where it's
like okay there's seven
so we're gonna have tissues now here's
your tissue it's a little bit gross
but like yeah
if they were in an emergent situation
mommy's the garbage can the booger
holder whatever well how did it yes it
went somewhere but my point is i was
excited to have some work well how do
you balance though how do you about like
you get a job and then how do you study
and learn your lines and do your work
and then balance the mom life with the
with the kids obviously the 22 year old
can help out he could babysit sometimes
when you need it or watch them and you
the person that goes the most
kind of crazy with it is me because
again i'm still
trying to detach i'm a very attached
parent and so now i'll go oh my gosh i'm
going to work 16 hours a day and maybe
only see them at night time
you know and i go through that kind of
scenario otherwise i
i'm a crammer now like
sorry homework
i do study it but right well i mean when
you're juggling kids or life or whatever
you're also you know you're kind of
studying as you go the best you can i
mean you know there's a lot of down time
on set it doesn't matter so you learn
wait wait so you can learn your lines on
set
yeah
i just i'm always baffled by that how
someone can go on set
it's just a muscle but it's not that i
don't do it before here's what happens
is i usually read it a few times
right so i know what i'm doing and i
kind of have my own process of figuring
out what the character wants where
they're going to be at because you know
they never sh shoot sequentially as you
know that right
and then i hone it down to what's
happening each day
and then i know kind of review it
but if yeah if i get behind like when i
was working on saving hope and you're
like tom always talks about this too
it's like if you're in every scene every
day
um you can't memorize you get it
like you just you just can't catch up in
the same way like you want so badly to
go to sleep when you go home that you
maybe review your seven scenes but the
next day it's like there would be
moments where i'd be block
and then when they're lighting i'm back
there
just just gulping it back like
memorizing it as fast as i can but
doesn't that create a lot of anxiety for
you on set
or no i my brain likes to work that way
that's the strangeness is the more that
i work the more
frenetic i am the the more i'm able to
do a million things at once the more
calm my brain is my brain goes faster if
i have to sit
right so you don't like sitting you like
to always be doing something i do
and and talking to my therapist the
other day yes lovely lady that i talked
to what did your therapist have to say
about that to me erica one of the things
that your ego does to avoid the
discomfort of change in your life is
you've created tasks for yourself
haven't you i was like oh yes i've done
so many things today
and i clean the whole house and i've
like rearranged everything and then
there's surely there's something i can
do for lachlan and liam during the day
so to actually sit and go i'm gonna do
my today i did a yoga class
and then not really do much my brain is
like but i have these things that could
be done and i'm talking about like
getting your health care cards with the
right addresses on them getting your
nexus card going like stuff that
the world wouldn't end if you couldn't
do it that day right but i needed a huge
thing do you procrastinate do they get
does every day you have a list of things
to do and they get pushed to tuesday to
wednesday to thursday i have
different kinds of lists so i have
priority lists and then backup lists
and then like if i'm board lists ryan do
you have lists
you do what what are your on your lists
every day you have lists every day this
is why my engineer who you can't see but
you could hear his beautiful voice
hi uh not every day
uh
on weekends for sure i have like
oh you gotta replace the uh the parking
sticker at the front when you're on your
car's front window or just like you know
i wanna clean my desk or um
yeah uh just little things little things
to rearrange that tick boxes in your
brain so that uh you're more at ease
yeah and you accomplish these things
that you guys do you feel a sense of
accomplishment do you feel fulfilled
after you get these isn't it
yeah you feel better right productive
today
like some of it really is practical you
have to call if they have canceled your
credit card on you or
you have to that happened sit on the
line and and deal with your cell phone
if it's breaking or broken or you know
especially with mom moms or dads if dads
take on the role like basically to
organize a kid's schedule is hell
so if i want to do summer camp i have to
start looking at summer camps now
it's march
let
random competition between all these
crazy ladies myself included online
going what are the coolest camps that my
kids could go to this summer
and so you're always
that's just never-ending it's you know
my therapist once said
michael you're trying to get your inbox
to be empty your inbox will never be
empty there's always [ __ ]
you have lists too i have lists i have
lists and i really try to get them done
um i do push things like today i
cancelled a physical i just said i could
do it next week i just i don't want i
didn't sleep that well
so i you know so whatever but
there is a sense of accomplishment when
i wake up in the morning the first thing
i do is i make my bed i know it sounds
trivial
but i make my bed i drink water i you do
it too erica yeah
and you feel good if you don't do it you
feel like what a lazy [ __ ]
yeah
except just usually i'm like what a lazy
[ __ ] like i'm like way more
angry
really are you you're hard on yourself
anything and you can't even make your
god damn bad do you do do you do that do
you yell at yourself
yeah you do are you hard you're hard on
yourself you're that's that's always
been the case with you you're always
really hard on yourself
i think so it's i'm
some people would say i'm probably not
hard enough on myself but i would say
the voice in my head is is much more
intense than
like okay if it didn't happen it's okay
like if i didn't make my bed that's okay
right right
well what about what about like
auditions and things like that like you
still audition for things how do you
deal with rejection because 99 of this
business is rejected all the time i
don't care anymore do you really not
care anymore
i guess whatever man i can't do anything
about it
all i can do is
try not to be shitty when i go in
try not try to be in somewhat decent
shape and not look too old those are my
that's my bar don't look too fat or too
old
and please try to do a good job when
you're in there
i can't control the rest of it
that's true if you can't control it
right shelve it you know i used to
noodle about it or like the minute i had
an audition that would be in my mind
like i'd be thinking about whether i was
going to get it or not and now i forget
half the time if i've auditioned for
stuff oh yeah i did that
because now the other the other way of
looking at that is is she zen or does
she just never get auditions that she
goes out for anymore
which one is it
it's the second one no it's not you get
stuff
you get stuff you get offers you get
offers i i have offers but if i were to
like really look at i was talking to
somebody was asking for asking acting
advice which i always think is hard
because i think it's such a hard
business and so much stuff is
is is lottery and like placement and
people you know and then if you're in
the door
and you happen to be pleasant and
somewhat good at your job you may get
you might get hired again right yeah but
there's so little that you control
so i said to them you almost have to
love it
to a point of a bit of a masochism like
it's like you can't stop yourself from
doing it again and again and again you
know
so like same thing with auditions i
don't know how many years has gone since
stuff i've auditioned for i haven't
gotten
but it's been years
so who's the masochist like i just go
it's like running and hitting your head
against the wall sure i'll do it again
yeah sure i'll do it again i mean that's
all i can say to people that like how do
i get into the business
you just keep doing it because you love
it
and then you find caveats like different
types of ways that you can enjoy it um
yeah
people you know always tell me
that i have a good voice and i should do
more voiceover work and i'm like yeah i
know okay thanks
i'm oh for 63
in my last 63 uh auditions my voiceover
auditions i just never get them i never
get there and you don't even know why
because i i just freaking so random
it's so random
i remember sitting in for like some of
the stuff on saving hope and i was just
like
some of the reasons for people not to
get hired it was just crushing to me i
was just like
that person just like
they did the best they could they did a
great job i know exactly what they were
going through when they went out and it
was like
meh i just don't like him
you just don't like him like that's
that's the reason somebody just get a
job i'll tell you what they say that
they say that when you walk into a room
they know immediately if you're right
for the part or not you walk in like
nope let's just read them and get them
going i don't care how hard he worked
for i don't get unless you're you know
gary oldman and you go in there and also
then you give them something that
they're like wait a minute this guy just
gave us such brilliance that we have to
consider it but they say they know
you're not
or you happen to be like i knew that
there was a guy that was around for a
while that like he would hire these
girls they all look dissimilar and it
was just like they were hot like his
wife
and so they all got jobs and not that
they weren't talented they surely were
good at their job but they also happened
to remind him
of his wife and then a few years later
he didn't like his wife and so you
wouldn't want to remind him of his wife
like those are random things as an actor
you can't control
wow i didn't think about it like that
right yeah i mean it reminds you like
some hot girl from from the 20 that they
ate in their 20s and then it's just like
i just like her
i hate her
she looks crazy well you worked we
talked about this in the last podcast
but you were a casting director you were
like right you were a cast nurturing the
casting director assistant what was it i
worked in background
you worked in background so you would
hire background people
so like the casting agent
the background casting agent would call
me and be like i need this many people
that look kind of like this to work in
this kind of scene
and then i would go through my roster
and i'd find who i could
and then i would put them on a set
mostly usually small though
really
yeah because we were a modeling agency
and they only wanted pretty people in
there
inside of you is brought to you by
nissan
the future will be great
but today is just as incredible meet
nissan's most advanced lineup if you
can't get enough adrenaline there's the
all-new 400 hp nissan z or for your
off-road adventures check out the
all-terrain nissan frontier if you're
more of a spontaneous road trip type
person hop in the nissan pathfinder and
for something more electric there's the
stylish nissan aria so let's enjoy the
ride
2023 aria and z not yet available for
purchase expected availability this
spring for 2023 z and this fall for 2023
aria inside of you is brought to you by
geico geico asks how would you love a
chance to save some money on insurance
of course you would after all who
doesn't love a great deal right and when
it comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
[Music]
gee smallville yeah because they they
had what's her name on there they had
what's her name from lost remember
what's her name
eventually did you did you hire her as a
extra you did
you were the one who said evangeline
lily what is her name evangeline lilly
is
she's pretty she needs to be on the show
so she was an extra she was background
while we were filming smallville
yeah
damn do you want to know something crazy
please this is another crazy thing about
the business
i was in la
for pilot season when when loss came out
and up here they wanted to see me for
lost but i wasn't here
and so
they convinced angeline lilly to go in
for the audition
really you could have been unlost
but you got lois lane
right so i was fine but my point is
i had to get over that
there was a moment where i was just like
son of a [ __ ] but
well you i think you learn as you get
older as you get older but but again
that's
putting all of the scenarios as if you
could walk in and be that look like it
was all meant to be her thing
but as an actor you can get your head
totally twisted around with the idea and
sell yourself on the sentimentality that
but had i got in for that audition i
would have had the chance
yeah
yeah i i honestly i don't know if you've
ever had that or like been driving
around all day and see a billboard and
you're like
why did i talk about this maybe i didn't
maybe i did i'm sure in 204 episodes
i've talked about it
or michael something like that but what
i do
is i do the audition and they give you
what's called side so you have the sides
that you read it's the pages that you
read and the second i'm done i turn out
i walk out out of the casting director's
door
and i rip up the sides and i throw them
away and i walk out
you do that too absolutely yeah
ben scenes on set it's like it's [ __ ]
done it's done get it out of your head
next next what's next what's next
because it essentially doesn't matter
anywhere what's the most effed up story
you've had as a casting director or as
you know in in casting working in
casting have you seen some crazy [ __ ]
no because it never worked in casting
per se other than well it's background
you never had any background like
complain
[Laughter]
just not show up they would always be
texting me like 3am i can't go in i'm
drunk and i was like
[Music]
i just think i think the weirdest thing
was casting people and then ending up on
small though
yeah again you've told that story but i
just i i find it so i don't have any
other stories but i find it baffling
what are the odds someone who's whose
job it is to cast background or get
background to fill it up in the
on the shows
yeah gets that opportunity how did you
how did you get that opportunity again i
can't remember
uh
well i was still auditioning for stuff
when i was um working as an agent right
and nothing was happening really
nothing was i was just doing like the
regular shows in town like the stargate
and chris isaac show and all that right
so just trying to build up um my union
status and then do you know who saw me
audition for something and he brought me
to l.a was david nutter
nutter he saw you audition and yeah he's
something else i'm just slogging it away
again a park royale i was sitting out at
the bus stop and it was raining and i
was like [ __ ] i'm tired of doing this
were you gonna quit
where you think you're gonna quit acting
yeah i was just like it was done i
probably would get kind of keep going in
but be like kind of like
half dead fish it's just almost almost
gone right
um and then he he said he
he uh texted or emailed i guess my
manager said you're gonna go down to
test for tarzan
and i went down to test for tarzan as
the sister which i don't fit that role
at all and then they put me on a signing
um on a deal
but i didn't know what that was either
warner brothers holding deal right i
just remember sitting in the universal
hotel going hey you're not right for
this but they're going to put you on a
holding deal and everybody's freaking
out i was like i didn't get the part
like what are you guys doing
i was still like way behind on on the
significance of that and then i did a
little pilot called gramercy park
and i got the lead in that one so i
think it's just they knew me so that by
the time it came around um
that smallville was auditioning
they brought me in
how many times did you read for it
don't say once
once for korean and once for greg
but then i had to test
then you had the test yeah
and then we were arguing about this on
the weekend i still had to get the pass
from walling
the week the two days before a week are
you serious he says no no no but it was
like totally sure
so you had to pass casting you had to
pass greg being an executive producer
smallville you had to then go test for
the network and the studio fly down la
yeah so i tested for them i came back
saturday i had to come to the the studio
and do um tests you know for wardrobe
and hair and all that and then they're
like oh and while i'm at um they'll call
them on tom is here and you're gonna
read a scene with them and i was like
okay cool it's neat it'll help for
monday's work
but i was still kind of scared and of
course then you know me somebody who's
cast the show and then i'd seen him on
the show and i walked out and he was
lumbering in and i just turned and
walked right into it i was like oh
it's just so weird for me
and we went in and read the scene i
thought okay that went great but i
didn't know
that that was my final conflict
you what
the final gauntlet like if he had hated
me he could have punted me that was it
so you're arguing about he says there's
no way i could have and i was like
[ __ ] tom you're being he said i have
no chemistry with her guys this isn't
working they wouldn't have done it yeah
and here i was again chick from alberta
no clue thinking i got the job we'll
just read it'll be nice and i'll see you
on monday but i didn't know like if they
thought it was like dog made or
something really super annoying i mean i
know i'm annoying but annoying to the
part of like
i i couldn't bear to be in a room with
this person i don't think you're
annoying at all i think you're really
quirky and lovable you're quirky let's
let's redefine that as
really high energy i've said that many
times on the weekend and i met this very
high energy
wait a minute so you just saw tom you
were in vancouver for an autograph
signing for a con yeah and he's he told
you you have very high energy yeah well
he was talking in the panel right and he
was talking about how did you guys get
met and you meet each other
and then he talked about my high energy
i never would have thought you
would really kill you guys
i think do you go back and forth are you
can you be by yourself are you good at
being by yourself yes
for how long
long time when i wasn't saving hope i
didn't talk to anybody for like really
and then it got a little dark but i
would go out into the movies i go to
restaurants by myself i can sit inside
and watch tons of netflix and read books
and
i can spend a lot of time alone really
yeah you like it
i do
but i think when i'm going into the
world of like say having to do the
podcast or
um a tv show or whatever then maybe i
kind of make myself more jacked up or
more mac or whatever do you think you do
that inadvertently like subconsciously
you do
yeah let's see let's see if i can show
you a little bit more of call america no
no no
i like this one that goes
no i think you're you're fun why why
would you want to change who you are i
think i've had that whole that problem
my whole life i think i've always been
like [ __ ] i'm the annoying obnoxious
loud guy the center of attention this
i'm gonna be the cool guy well rosenbaum
that's not in the cards for you you just
weren't meant to be the cool guy you'll
never be the cool guy you could just be
yourself over here listen to your voice
it's cool guy boys yeah this is cool guy
be like hey man what's up man i'm out of
bed i listen to your radio show i mean i
know you do a podcast but you could do
like a morning wake up or an evening hey
ktla 107.5
yeah or like an evening meditation thing
i'd listen to that
hey folks it's meditation with mike
first we want to close our eyes close
your eyes
take a deep breath
i immediately want to listen and exhale
you're doing this for you
it's a whole other avenue what do you
think ryan should we do like should we
do a meditative uh one hour that i could
put out there in the app space that you
could listen to my voice right now many
people would listen to it i i i don't
think so well guys write in tell me if
you want an app rosencom rosencom
instead of rosenbaum if you want the app
maybe i'll do it maybe i'll put it on
itunes or whatever and you know it'll be
for fun
breathe i just have to write it out and
then don't go great
no but they do that they go
there's nothing to worry about
it's just you
that's it
it's just you and me halfway
you're all alone it's just me and you
breathe deeply
uh 20th anniversary of smallville just
happened and um
you know they got the blu-rays out and
you know all the stuff tom and i did
some press and
uh
what do you think it's pretty it's
pretty crazy it's been 20 years now you
got involved in what season
five four
four right here yeah season four so you
were with the show for
seven six out of the ten years nine
years
seven what do you remember
what good memories do you honestly have
like do you come to you right away not
that you have to search for but what are
some some moments that you have that you
remember
i was happy every time i was walking for
my trailer to set i was excited i
remember marching there in my little
fry boots ready to march in and
just be in in the studio and have fun
and i mean i really literally
loved it the only times i was ever
really pissed is when it was three in
the morning
and i was in this dropless dress and i
was cold
and welling or you were wearing like
[ __ ] suits but otherwise i
i loved it i was so excited to go in and
do the different scenes i thought the
sets were like when i first got there
and i looked at these real sets because
i had no idea what to expect i thought
it would be like
like a tin can or something and a couple
chairs right like and then you walk in
and it's a real barn and it's a real
house and
you know the vibe of everybody wanting
to produce and do something really cool
together that was excited about it i
thought that that was really neat
um
i liked the stunts i loved that every
time i went in i did something different
like every episode i was doing something
completely different in the first couple
of years i was like i called myself the
bum pump
check which one was like basically
say the punchline ha ha boom
yeah like there'd be a really important
heartfelt scene and then i would come in
at the end and ruin it somehow then i'd
march off
which was fine i was like that's
probably all i could handle at that
point i was so stressed out
um i love the small little backlight
the diamond
the back lot when we got closer to the
last few years we actually had a full
lot in the back it made me feel like we
were on the warner brothers studio you
liked that and it was just
yeah we could do all our walking talks
and
i honestly am not cheesy person i really
loved it you just enjoyed it all but i
remember i remember you very old
that stuff annoyed me yeah of course the
rain and cold of vancouver but i
remember you also being
um
incredibly lovable charming great to
work with but i do remember that
nervousness sometimes
and that's a little bit much the
pressure no it was the pressure you put
on yourself it didn't it didn't affect
anybody else it was just affecting you
in your head because you just had to be
and i have that issue too or i have to
be great i have to be great it has to be
great i have to get this i i don't want
to you know let people down i don't want
to let it's just like it's it's
it's that insecurity i've talked about
with a lot of people and you know you
try to again you try to be cool and
you're like all right did i do a good
job am i are you sure you got it you
know are we moving on are you sure you
want to move on or you're like shut the
[ __ ] up
but you i'm talking about that
i had that all the time and part of it
now i realize and
is my waiver
and you know you're hearing this people
talk about this all the time but you
know you go through therapy and you
realize so much stuff
um from your childhood and it isn't even
the fault of the parent trying to do
things or not doing things it's it's
a child's response to their environment
my environment was very rule-based
and very much
get along with everybody be a good
person never put anybody out and if
you're paid to do a job you do it right
which means in my mind because i'm a
perfectionist don't [ __ ] make a
mistake they paid you to know these
lines and if you don't know them when
you come on what the [ __ ] is your
problem you should know them that was
your job you signed on to do it so
um a little intense
but that's just part of
that was your mentality because that's
what all you knew and also you know
i joined into the show being a chick
from alberta who's not in you know just
trying to get in the business and then
i'm
working on a show this everybody's doing
so well
you know you've got kristen who's just
kristin she's like a walking talking
breathing non
and like she's like
she looks like she's walked out of a
magazine right and so i was so
intimidated by her first and foremost
and she's been working forever
and she's so composed within herself and
of course later if anybody watches her
stuff you realize that some of that is
her own
ability to socialize and those kinds of
things but all i saw was i was quite
intimidated
and then you guys are from l.a big
actors from l.a and you know so i kind
of always felt like i was off a step
right to prove myself
did you feel like you didn't belong
ah
not not even as much as you guys not
being nice to me but i really felt like
i i had stepped into a space like i kept
going like
how am i here
that's but let me tell you
how do i still stay here and i'm not
saying that from a space of like no it's
understandable where you where you were
coming from i didn't know about myself
but i really didn't get it i kept
feeling like i was not
how did i land in this thing
and yeah oh crap i got to work they
calling me you were incredibly grateful
but at the same time why am i here
that i've been there where i'm like oh
my god they cast me i did it i did it i
did it i fooled them i fooled them and
we hear that all the time from actors i
fooled them and they're gonna fire me
now now i've gotta be even better i've
gotta be on my feet i gotta you know uh
yeah or like having no clue what it is
and they'll be like that was so great i
just loved it i'm like
there but they liked it okay you were
always good though it paid off whatever
whatever you did whatever got you there
or whatever stress and it sucks and the
anxiety and everything
on screen you never would have known you
looked so confident that you just
i thought you tore it up i thought you
were you popped
well definitely you know when you can
when you do end up watching yourself
there are times or i don't know if you
even watch like
10 years ago you on a screen and 10 year
like now on a screen if you ever see any
blips of your work you can definitely be
like oh whoa she was still learning a
lot of stuff there
but
but you know not me not me i look at it
and go man you were good what happened
you were so good what happened man
yes and then part of me goes you still
got it come on you still got it inside
you you got it you just got to show it
you got to want it get out the eye of
the tiger man
you know i don't want to get into it too
much but it's kind of like you know i
don't think we got into it really last
time but you know you said you always
said allison was really nice to you
right you worked with allison matt how
honest do you want me to be i want you
to be really honest i don't i don't want
you to call me up though afterwards and
go cut that out
[Laughter]
no but feel free to talk about it but
like you know were you that
because she she came to me everybody
knows that she came up to me and welling
oh rosemont you'd really excel in this
there's this you know
self-help thing and blah blah blah and i
go
yeah
yeah i don't know i looked at tom i'm
kidding jokingly i just said sounds like
cold doesn't it but like you know i
didn't do it but like did she ever try
to get you to do it
yes she did because she tried to get
laura as well she tried to recruit laura
the idea of sharing
all of my personal secrets
brings up a vissel visceral reaction in
me as well
wait a minute so that came up right away
that like this is no no this like
well she didn't bring it up into the
latter part of the seasons right right
you know we had an interesting
relationship
me and allison right i think i think she
felt like she wanted to like me i think
she felt like she
wanted people to see that she liked me
but i don't think she really i don't
think having me there was something that
was great for her
so she thought maybe you say that
potentially
maybe she was a little threatened by oh
and there's this new girl that just came
on the podcast
threatened but i just i found that there
was too many little idiosyncrasies of
things that would happen where i'd walk
away and i was like
i thought we got along today and then i
would go home and i'd be like but that
was super mean but nobody would see it
right right like so there is all sorts
of those little things that would go on
so
um and perhaps it was something that she
was working on too and that's why some
days it would be like she's maybe really
working on trying maybe we're just two
different people
i don't know but it would be like some
days it would be like she was super
happy to see me and super friendly and
other days
you know it was not quite the same right
and uh
and so
yeah we weren't ever really close but
she liked you enough or hated you enough
to invite you into the
into the i guess that yeah i think that
was about her like to be honest i think
she wanted to she like being in that
position of knowledge and and wanting to
recruit and bring people in i think she
obviously really believed in it
um
but i just i have to say i just didn't
really trust her motivation when it came
to me
okay you just felt like she didn't
really like you she didn't really
connect with you
oh somebody didn't like me and i'm like
in kindergarten or something it's just
the vibe that she gave me was not
something that i thought oh i feel like
i can really trust you with myself and
my innermost thoughts right
that makes perfect sense
okay so that's kind of our main
experience and then yeah she did
approach me to talk about it and should
i i should do this thing and it'd be
really good for me and
um
it was too reminiscent of i didn't trust
it and it was too reminiscent of like a
very
right right wing version of my
upbringing which was confess your sins
to your
everybody around you to keep you on the
straight and narrow but you're talking
about humans there so it's never going
to be this glorified idea of helping
each other it's going to be like
i know your [ __ ] let's talk about each
other so i didn't find that to be
somewhere i wanted to put myself right
you know what i mean like i'll get my
therapist or i'll get someone else but
i'm not going to join a group of people
and then talk about my personal [ __ ]
with them i'll tell you it sounds you
know the the first time when she did
mention i thought oh
you know there's a bunch of other people
they're very supportive you build
confidence you build all these things
you learn about yourself you know the
idea sounds kind of cool
yeah that's how they get you right
your [ __ ] and have a sense of community
and i think
we're all looking for that we're all
looking for a sense of community so
we're all a little gullible a little
naive
but i had been as a child growing up and
a really conservative christian
environment seen and been party to
um
those kind of experiences where you
confess your deep dark secrets and you
promise to uphold each other and pray
for each other and help each other and
it's just not a human
possibility right
yeah no like not in not with that many
people you might have one or two
confidants where you could say
okay this is something you really want
to work through and i'd like you to hold
me accountable because i have a problem
with this
but on mass i've never seen that work
well i've always seen that used as a
tool to
manipulate people
or
if not manipulate then the larger group
of people would shame some some people
because of that so i'd seen that in in
my own life and i'd seen that with
my family and and so i was like
not for me not for me
not for me yeah no i understand that
makes that makes perfect sense it makes
perfect sense
uh
who is your toughest toughest critic in
your family i'm talking mom dad brothers
what did it what is it who is the one
that you try to impress that you try to
like you hope you like your work that
they don't say much to you about your
work
that
is the hardest because we all have
somebody in our family
mine is my dad he's just like you know
he doesn't say much
of anything at all
um
this this sounds like a cop out they're
all supportive of my work but i would
say the voice in my head of the person
that i always that would it would be my
mother
yeah
yeah like i think that letting her down
by either like you know an attack by
howard stern or
doing a part that was
you know when i was a kid doing
something topless doing those those
kinds of things i was always worried
to let her down even though i know
nothing i did do would let her down but
she's my voice in my head right
you know mom
yeah
makes sense all right the best lady i
know i'm not knocking her but she
definitely is like when that stuff
happened i went
[Music]
whoa i just went against like every
single thing my mom tried to program
into me not just well we got to go our
own way fleetwood mac said it you got to
go your own way and sometimes along that
way you're going to fall or sometimes
you're going to look like an idiot or
sometimes you're going to be a little
embarrassed and that's all part of it
i'm i'm mortified half my uh half of my
life
but you know the thing with my mom which
i find interesting is like i worry about
all those things but then she's my
deepest supporter if that makes sense
so
it's almost like i've imagined i put her
in this space of judgment but that she's
not actually in that space
that's my own judgment and she's
like anytime i've talked to her about
any of those kinds of things like her
her support and her love and her
understanding of humanity and stuff is
just boom it's there right so as you
know probably i don't know if you
figured out when you do
if you i don't know if you do it um but
i'm currently doing therapy it's like
the narrative that you create is your
narrative right
and it may not actually be what's
happening right in mouse's head yeah we
kind of put it there
huh
that makes me think a lot by the way
with all your pieces and all the things
that you're you know insecurities and
then the cool thing is is once you start
realizing that then you can kind of go
oh
i'm putting this on there because
this is a thing for me right i didn't
know you were topless in something oh
yeah it was awful really
awful yeah you hated it how many years
ago was that
i was 20. it was my last credit to get
in the union
wow were you were you nervous that had
to be crazy and you know what i have to
say i didn't want to do it i mean it was
it was not a pleasant experience for me
and i would challenge anybody who's
young who feels like they don't want to
do that stuff i don't know anybody who'd
have the hoots but to do it maybe the
girls of this generation more power to
them but i remember i was kissing my
on-screen boyfriend matt he's just a
lovely person
and i was crying and i was like i don't
want to do this
he's like you don't have to do this i
was like i have to do this and then i
just continue to do the scene where i
like tease him when i go out into the
water and i
write right and it looked awful it was
terrible
and you know they didn't tell me about
like it's supposed to be topless and
then it ended up being i oh let's take
your pants off to you and then i hadn't
prepared myself for that so then i was
wearing really inappropriate underwear
so like it ended up being like a full-on
basically they took advantage of you
sounds like and then i find out later
from all my friends who are in
in um
crew and everything they're like oh yeah
we we had our stunt girl one guy was
carrying a hose the other guy was
carrying like it wasn't a closed set i
didn't know about that i was so [ __ ]
scared
my thing but i'm so driven too so my
brain was like
six credits i'm in the union then i can
be a union background performer and i
can make twenty dollars an hour
and then i can try to audition for
bigger parts and so my brain just went
[ __ ] do it eric i like to get past
all the stuff from your childhood this
is your awful
and now i realize no that's probably
part of my makeup like i really didn't
want to do that thing if you can go back
in time you would not never done it
i would have had the i would have said
no
you would have said no yeah i know a lot
of women sit here and go no regrets i
learn yeah i learned from it
but
i wish
and what i'm learning now
is that
it's okay to use your voice
say what you need to say yeah don't give
a [ __ ] about whether it's gonna upset
the day
or upset a bunch of people on set
but it's not your thing it's not your
thing
you know and that's what i would have
told my 20 year old self
wow words of wisdom i like that i like
that no it is smart
do it but uh this is [ __ ] talking with
erica durants uh these are questions
from my lovely patrons go to patreon.com
inside of you and join patreon and
support the podcast even more these are
questions here we go sophie m if there
were a book
of your life
what would the title be
this is funny
i don't know
how about wild child
yeah i like that a lot better wild child
there's a jim morrison book about jim
morrison
wild child wild child
uh leanne serious question from one
canadian to another milk in a carton or
bag bag
they say babe
carton
milk in a carton
except for when i was a kid it was in a
bag because we got it right from the
cows or
on rough rough times we had powdered
milk oh boy oh no i have not
those are the rough days where you're
just like this is what we got left let's
make us mix up this it's not that bad
dana s where is your happy place when
the world is too loud besides the
bathtub
where's your happy place
they could be on in the bed reading a
book it could be in a park it could be
uh it could be wherever it could be back
home with your mom and dad it could be
anywhere
oh my god
when the world is too loud happy
um
therapy i have a
bench hidden in the woods somewhere that
i sit on you do
yeah and how often do you go to that
bench
well it depends on how many times i need
to be how i how often a few times a week
and you spend an hour there
uh as much time as i can and i just
stare
it's that peaceful that happy it's that
happy of a place
yeah
yeah and i it's because the trees just
go on and on and on and on and on
um that's awesome
that's really cool
i don't have a bench in the woods
but you know that's kind of the romantic
version sometimes my happy place
when i'm at home when my kids are here
and they're
sleeping is to
go into my closet
shut the door and listen to some music
wow ryan what's your happy place
what's ryan's happy place i'll have to
think about that
uh
there was a time in my 20s i lived near
the beach and i would take myself down
to the burrito place i'd go grab a
burrito and i'd sit on the beach and eat
my burrito that was a great time
just by yourself buy your lonesome yeah
out in playa del rey what's the place
called you remember yeah it's just the
beach out in playa del rey or the the
the burrito place i think it's still
there it's called senor g's senor jeez
it was just there
i like it yeah i'm trying to think of my
happy place
you know in my guest room bed
about you know taking a nap with my dog
there's just something just peaceful and
i just sunk out for 40 minutes or an
hour and just yeah or just like lie
there with my dog
just beautiful
something about the animal yeah
huge difference you know my therapist my
somatic therapist i have different
therapists for different things but my
somatic therapist says
try breathing with your dog
like the same breaths as your dog kind
of get in sync
so you lie there with your dog and you
try to do it it's kind of peaceful it's
kind of peaceful with an animal i don't
know maybe it sounds weird they know how
to
they know how to do that and it's a
strange thing to say when i'm reading a
book called breathe and it's talking
about how over the course of a very very
long time this
humans have forgotten how to breathe
properly
even to the point that has changed our
um evolution it's changed the shape of
our jaws and inside our nasal chambers
and that's part of why some people like
they they go to sleep therapy clinics
all that kind of stuff because the
actual inside of our skulls have changed
because of our lack of ability to
breathe
because we've allowed
whatever it is in our life
to keep us from breathing and i wonder
if there's something innately like with
your dog or something that they just
know
i do it right and we like our emotions
are
spaces we stop we do shallow breath or
short breath or we hold our breath or i
don't breathe enough i i do not breathe
enough a lot of times during this
interview i'm sitting here and sometimes
i'm just
i i actually think about it i go breathe
i just go we forget to do it
so there's a book called breathe
breathe with me raj tell me about the
worst haircut you ever got what the hell
ron
yeah um
when i was in grade 11 i loved having
short hair i had short hair for a really
long time
um in high school
and when i was in grade 12 i got a
haircut
and as it grew out i started i looked
like one of the beatles
perfect which one ringo
so like it was just like that
bowl cut
and that's what i had for my my grad
photo beautiful i'm gonna see that
picture you're gonna have to send it to
me please see if i can find it it's
pretty spectacular lisa h lois was a big
white snake fan in smallville i didn't
know this
uh but what about you
where apparently she made them upload
white snake they sing is this love i
listen to is this love that i'm feeling
is this the love
and they also sing what's that other
song isn't it here we go again um oh i
love that one isn't that it that's it i
went to a phase where i played that over
and over and over again
when i was running bob k no question
just to thank you for your honesty and
your sincerity
and my severity sincerity not your
severity
bob
he says thank you for your honest
honesty and
your sobriety no no no your sincerity
your sincerity thank you for my severity
but i am very severe at times so thank
you bob you're you're a very sincere
person i think when you say hi to
someone when you haven't seen so you're
very genuine you're very sincere
do you feel the same way about me
actually yeah that's a selfish question
really
do
well i do care when i ask you how you
are i really do care yeah that's why you
do well in your podcast yeah i don't
care about every everybody i interview
sometimes i'm just like all right
whatever
but most people they open up you open up
you share
stories in person and then you know what
i noticed it's not always um
the sign of good characters not the
people that are good to
good to everybody on mass it's the
people that are good
to to the ones that look like they have
they're a little bit broken or they're
like the outcasts or the broken bird or
whatever and i've witnessed countless
times where we've been at conventions or
with people on set or you'll you can
it's like you hone in on anybody that
like a little bit uncomfortable and you
go right to them
that's the kind of character for me
i mean you tear up a little bit i don't
know why maybe tear up a little bit
because i do always love going
b-lining i can see you literally feel it
here and you go to those people and i
think it's magnificent i just feel
there's something in me that goes i'm
gonna make that person feel good somehow
i'm gonna do it i just need to i want to
i have to
um that's that's funny that you say that
no one's ever really said that no one
said that to me that's that's weird but
i think that one of like the major
characteristics that i see of you well
now i
your kindness but kindness like people
oh be kind it's not it's kind to the
ones
that need it the most
yeah that's that's a unique thing but i
i appreciate that and i'm not gonna i'm
gonna take that compliment i'm gonna i'm
gonna keep it inside and i'm not gonna
say no come on and you know what people
always do that people was like yo you're
so pretty you're like no stop my hair
was bad i didn't shower i didn't you
know i know you look really pretty
really just take it take the compliment
ryan you look really handsome you shaved
you look really handsome buddy
yeah like what would be the worst thing
in the world if you want to just as we
age just go oh thank you thank you thank
you i have a restful settled place to be
yeah
well it does after you feel like i gotta
feel visited the dead space quick flip
into a new topic
they just complimented me and i can't
take it
when do you go film
um
march 21st for how long
just for the three weeks where label
vancouver vancouver
babies you get to be home
yeah what a treat
i know i'm very excited about it uh is
hallmark a negotiable thing with your
contract or can you negotiate with them
or they just said this is your salary
this is what you get here we go we can
negotiate oh but everything is within
reason and i think it's also given each
project
right
so i kind of look at the project
like how high are you on the list right
three four five down the list you're not
gonna be like this is my rate are you
number one
and this one i think so oh
number one gets to negotiate i'm not
quite sure because i haven't there's
another another character in there that
actually i think should take precedence
but i don't know if it'll end up
happening that way
it doesn't matter to me but but what it
does matter is when you go into
negotiations like there used to be this
kind of thing in the business where it'd
be like i made this once on one movie
ten years ago i wasn't paying me now for
everything it's it's totally different
different production company different
studio different everything this is how
much i'm contributing this is my my rate
and then you work otherwise i think yeah
likely work would diminish quite a bit
well
this has been awesome i think you're an
amazing person inside out i love talking
to you i'm glad we did this again i want
to do it every year as a ketchup that
would be great yeah this is this is so
much fun and i i just i love when you
open up you're very open you're a very
open person you kind of although i never
thought that of you but you
i never would have thought it the first
time i had you on the podcast before
that i was like
i don't know if she wants to talk about
anything personally at all and you do
you open up about who you are and you
know and in life and it's just it's
it's a breath of fresh air really
thank you yeah and i'll leave it at that
i appreciate your time thank you for
allowing me to be inside of you again
my pleasure
when am i going to see you i might see
you when at a con i guess we do i don't
know are you doing liverpool i might do
liverpool
liverpool then so we'll have dinner in
liverpool i would love that i love it i
love you
say that i love youtube
what would you say how cool is it to say
i'll see you in liverpool we're gonna
have dinner oh yeah that is cool i'll
see you in liverpool has gotten you down
you go i got to say something like that
that's really cool
it is cool
we'll have dinner with liverpool
okay all right i love your face
she's great she's great she's like me
she's she's a bit of a warrior
she uh she gets anxiety she gets these
you know and she's uh but she's got a
huge heart
and uh thank you erica thank you for
putting up with me
and ryan you know ryan's here you know
you got to put up with him too so well
that was she didn't have to look at me
the whole time that's true she has to
look at me which is not easy all the
time
i wish she'd come over in person though
she wasn't in person no erica next time
you're going to fly to la and you are
going to stay in the guest room and you
are going to if you need a place to stay
that is and you are going to sit where
ryan's sitting and i'm going to
interview you live chris kristen krug i
want to do that with too
but uh anyway
it is nice when they're here it is it's
nice when they're here it just gives me
an energy and a lot of people have been
coming in we just had nathan fillion on
the show he'll be that will be airing
soon and uh the judah apatow thank you
for listening to the judge interview if
you have
if you haven't listened to judd apatow
it's one of my favorites and ryan one of
his favorites uh it went really well get
a lot of good press from that and a lot
of uh positivity judd actually uh
messaged me saying how much he enjoyed
it and uh the response has been great so
that's fantastic judd thank you
and uh right now why don't i read the
top tier patrons
um also all the stuff i mentioned before
uh just listen to the intro about uh the
new the stages coming up so you can
watch our music and the cons that i'll
be at they're all in the intro so if you
want to hear where i'm going to be
where you can meet me all that stuff
go
to the intro uh right now let's do the
shout outs these are the top tier
patrons they are the folks that really
give back to the podcast and help keep
it afloat uh go to patreon.com inside of
you and big thanks to my editor jason
jason elkin thank you love you buddy
great job ryan here my right-hand man
ryan tayz and we got bryce mallors who's
uh my producer and the ladies over at uh
westwood one well cumulus um agnes
catrin and teresa um
yeah so thank you here we go top tier
patrons you get a shout out this is one
of the perks by being a top tier patron
you get your name shouted out
shout it shout it shout it out loud you
know if i had my phone on here i'd play
the beginning a little clip of uh a new
song that's coming out
oh is that one of yours one no no that's
a actually kiss
the van kiss but it's always something i
don't know it's always something in
philadelphia huh what what it's always
something in philadelphia oh it's always
sunny in philadelphia here we go nancy d
leah sarah v little lisa yukiko jill e
bryant h nico p robert b jason w kristen
k raj c joshua
j p jennifer n stacy l jamal f janelle b
kimberly mike e eldon sopremo 99 more
ramira
santiago
m correct chad wlenp
maya p
maddie
s correct
belinda n chris h dave h sheila g brad d
ray h tabitha t tom and liliana a talia
m betsy d
chad l rochelle marion meg k dan and big
stevie w angel m rhiannon c corey k
super sam dev nixon michelle a jeremy c
andy t cody r gavinator david
h c correct david c john b brandy d
yabor camille as the
see joey
um pants you were right um you went um
and correct joe that's right that's joey
william david h omar i design otg eugene
n
leah oh it wasn't eugene n eugene end
yeah sorry about that chris p nikki g
cory nicole patricia heather l jake b
james b bobbitt joshua b tony g megan t
mel s orlando c orlando hi orlando
orlando c and john b caroline r rob e
paul c christine ace eight s christine
ace
uh sarah s er eric h spring jennifer r
shane r and emma
are like three r's just remember
jennifer r shane r m r just in case i
ask you next time three hours in a row
the reading writing arithmetic of uh
patrons
yeah
um
hey guys thank you all i gotta say is
thank you for uh listening again to the
podcast and i'm not gonna you know i
think it gets in my head when people
sometimes occasionally leave a comment
like that where it's just like you know
just get to it or you know i'm like so i
want to fast forward through [ __ ] but i
don't this is my [ __ ] show
i don't need to do that you don't need
to tell them that you're fast forwarding
you can just do it
yeah
it's fine it's part of it it's part of
it it's part of it it's just go just
fast forward a little jingle and then
you'll know when the interview starts i
hope you don't fast sword i hope you uh
listen to the beginnings um you know in
case you want merch or sometimes there's
a discount on merch and sometimes
there's you know concerts that you can
go to and and things like that this is
true don't skip it yeah don't skip the
front listen to every
set i mean if they're still here they're
they're my loyals
if you're still here right now listening
you're a loyal because most people have
turned me off already they're done
listening to my voice you got home from
work and you just sit in your car it's
parked and you're waiting for this to
end before you go inside yes that's
right so i should hurry up or
drag it out maybe they don't want to go
home i don't want you to go home i'm
going to stay here and i'm going to talk
to you i want to keep talking to you do
you hear me
uh thank you for allowing me to be
inside of you today and each week uh i
appreciate you tuning in please spread
the word get everybody you know to watch
and listen and write a review
and uh from myself michael rosenbaum
here in the hollywood hills of
california
it was gravely this time was it was it
hey hey i'm ryan tez right
the hollywood hills california
california volume hey big wave to the
camera we love you guys be good to
yourselves that's the number one thing i
will say every week is always just be
good to yourself no matter how hard it's
going how hard it is for you
take a deep breath and go [ __ ] there's
always tomorrow man because there is
tomorrow and i will see you tomorrow or
next week all right take it easy
[Music]